who is deku's Dad we know that his name  is Hisashi midoriya that he has a fire  breathing Quirk and that he apparently  works abroad but that's basically all we  know about him there are a ton of  theories flying around about why we  still haven't seen him in the story like  that he's an international spy or that  he's secretly a villain or that he was  turned into a gnomu but the most popular  theory is that deku's real father is  actually all for one horikoshi the  creator of mha loves Star Wars  references they're literally everywhere  so a lot of people think that Deku and  over one have like an Anakin and Darth  Vader situation going on in the past  horikoshi has said that he does plan to  introduce deku's father at some point in  the story and since we are basically in  the final Arc this has to happen very  soon subscribe to the channel for more  anime Mysteries like